my life changed a couple years ago when
I discovered something called the
progress principle when you are starting
off with anything you're gonna be really
bad at it period
one of the things that you're gonna have
to become great at is letting all of the
noise drift away into nothing and
getting into laser focus on the thing
that you're working on
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's that belief nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and make a difference
using it so let's start your day off
where I grab your cup of coffee and sip
on today's message use the progress
principle over to you Mel Robbins my
life changed a couple years ago when I
discovered something called the progress
principle it is a principle that was
written about in the Harvard Business
Review it's based on a tremendous amount
of research done by a professor over
there and what she determined is that
people that feel happy and successful
and fulfilled by their lives and work
they all have one thing in common they
feel as though they're making progress
on something that matters so I read this
little bit of research and I started
applying it to my life and what I do as
as stupid as it sounds it really works I
don't focus on balancing everything I
focus on just making sure that I make
progress on one thing a day that's right
you heard me one thing a day that
matters to me now if I can make progress
on one thing a day that matters to me
then I can let go and let the rest of my
day get hijacked by kids by spouse by
phone calls by emails by social media by
all kinds of things that come up and
tend to hijack your day when you're a
busy person when you have a family when
you're married when you got a lot going
on and so by focusing on one thing a day
I feel the sense of control in the sense
of progress that science tells us will
make you happy and make you feel more
confident and actually make you more
effective at getting things done it also
frees me up to be more present with my
kids so I love the progress principle
and I'm gonna take a little different
spin on it that I think might add some
extra context or extra value for you
guys I think when you are starting off
at anything you're gonna be really bad
at it period you want to make videos
your first video is gonna be really bad
you're gonna be embarrassed by me and
look at and say wow I really suck and
the tendency from there is to then quit
because you might look at a Mel Robbins
speaker and say wow she's so good on
stage I wish I could be like her and
then you got up and you try to do a
simple speech or a simple video and you
can't it's really really really really
bad and then a lot of people from there
to stop we're what you need to realize
is using the progress principle you can
have an aspirational person like Mel
Robbins that you want to be like her you
want to write a book like her you want
to speak like her you want to
youtube-channel occur you want to be you
know a keynote like her she's the best
version of what you want to look like
and then focus on I just need to make
progress from who I was yesterday I'm
gonna make one video it's gonna suck but
tomorrow I'm gonna make another video
and it's still gonna suck but hopefully
it sucks just a little bit less than
what I did yesterday and then the same
thing the next day and the same thing
the next day in the same thing the next
day and so the progress is that you are
getting better at this thing
I think too often we look at these
aspirational leaders which is amazing to
do but we use it not as a kick forward
but a kick down we see someone like Mel
who's amazing at what she does then we
feel we can never be like that we should
quit we should give up on our dreams and
just go back and do that nine-to-five
job that you hate no that's not the
answer like expect to be terrible at the
beginning of anything and then use the
progress principle to just make progress
every single day if that's your goal to
be a great speaker like Mel then
practice saying speaking once a month is
not gonna get you there you will feel
really slow you'll feel the Thar GQ feel
like you're not making progress like
your dreams are not happening and so
making sure that every single day even
if it's 20 minutes you spend 20 minutes
trying to be a better speaker every day
if you did that I guarantee you you'll
be a better speaker you may not find the
point
not be one day that it just all clicks
but if you look back at the progress
just like losing weight it's not like
you do a whole bunch of work nothing
happens and then boom you're 20 pounds
lighter that's not how it works
so how anything works it's the skill set
that gets better you lose weight
gradually right and yes if you're doing
a good job with your diet and exercise
you can lose weight faster but it's
still a process getting to be a better
speaker getting to be the person who has
the skills to do the thing that you want
to do so you can match the skills that
you need to have to the ambition that
you have developing those skills is
still a process even if your mom's
success and you're hacking and you're
working every single day it's still a
process that you have to go through to
get there and too many people get so
discouraged along the process that they
quit and really I love using a progress
principle in this way and that every day
you're just trying to do a little bit
better than you did yesterday and you
didn't love having these aspirational
leaders to look up to that's the
inspiration that's where you're gonna
get to but the most important thing is
that you got better then you were
yesterday and if you do that enough like
you'll feel it you'll feel the sense of
growth the sense of accomplishment the
momentum that you couldn't do this thing
yesterday and now you kind of date it a
little bit better and you're gonna be a
little bit better the next day
you don't have to take 350 videos like I
did before you weren't absolutely
embarrassed there's 350 videos before I
was absolutely embarrassed by my own
content where most people would give up
after 3 or 2 or 1 or 7 and then that's
it and they can't be speaker and so if
you study the success stories of all the
people that you look up to you'll see
that there may be a point in time where
we're public the public deemed them to
be successful but they built up their
skill sets over a period of years or
decades to get to the point where they
got noticed or broke through and
nowadays it's only easier and easier and
easier and easier and easier to get
noticed and to break through if you have
the skills so get work on the skills
every day to get a little bit better now
I've got a really special bonus clip
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
first question of the day I want to know
what is the skill that you're working on
that you want to make progress on that
every day you want to make
a little bit a little bit a little bit
better leaving the comments below
believe nations cheering you on so share
it I want to see it thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of an espresso and enjoy
the bonus clip
[Music]
this question is from Phroso mara new on
YouTube when your home life is less than
desirable it's not where you want to be
living but you're trying to break out
how do you not let the chaos around you
affect your vision and drive so this is
a framing question so what you want to
do and this this Tony Robbins asked this
question I think it's absolutely
brilliant how is the worst thing that
ever happened to me
the best thing that ever happened to me
so in your circumstance how is being in
a chaotic home life the best thing ever
now I'll give you one example off the
top of my head and this is exactly why I
play first-person shooters can you learn
to stay calm in the chaos because my
friend I have the chills if you can do
that it will serve you so well in every
single area of your life in a
relationship in business if you want to
be an athlete if you want to play games
like what ever it is that you do one of
the things that you're gonna have to
become great at is letting all of the
noise drift away into nothing and
getting into laser focus on that thing
you're working on now when I give advice
like that to people they think well how
do I practice the amazing news is the
best thing that has ever happened to you
is that you have a built-in way to do
that your home life is mass chaos so now
you get a chance to practice I have the
chills you get a chance to practice
every day tuning out the chaos and
getting laser focused on something
that's framing now there are other ways
but that one is so powerful that I will
end it there focus on that it is
practice practice every day thank God
you're living in this chaotic
environment man congratulations gives
you something to focus on but let me
step back so me you can't focus because
let's just face it you know social media
makes money by making you unfocused
scientists have studied how Facebook
Instagram Twitter all of these apps have
created addictions and that's how why
the people who own them are the richest
people in the world now I use social
media so I'm not going to say don't use
social media hello practical tip for
2018 turn off all notifications
patience on my phone I don't have one
notification on so if you have an iPhone
go to settings right here
go stroll down and notifications where's
my notifications right there turn
everything off look at mine
show previews never off off every single
one is off okay because I'm not a sucker
I use social media but social media is
not gonna use me I'll look at my
facebook when I want to not what Mark
Zuckerberg wants me to dopamine is
released by these apps it's literal
physical addictions created by these
again you can use social media but don't
let it use you so just a little
practical thing turn off the damn social
media notifications Instagram won't be
there you got to be reminded every time
someone deems you why are you too dumb
that you can't remember that Instagram a
notification if you can't remember it
that means it's probably not important
so he's the win-win situation you've got
more time and less distraction so focus
in 2018 I gave you the first thing to
focus on which is your social life
you're gonna have to focus you know I I
don't know how to draw a horse very well
but I'll just use a square with a head
every time I try to draw people are like
you're horrible at drawing so I am
horrible so horse I used to have a horse
and they put these things on the side of
horses right here
they're called blinders they don't
really blind the horse but they the
horse can only see straight ahead and
the reason they do that is because when
you're out on the road with a horse I
live with the Amish for two years if a
big car comes by and the horse sees that
out of the corner of their eye they get
scared and I actually knew a guy he was
driving along the side of road there was
a cliff on the edge that he didn't put
the blinders on that horse to focus the
horse a big truck was coming the horse
saw and kind of went like that a side
boo no he didn't die but he won't run
off the cliff got in
got thrown off three four five six
months rehabilitating from their injury
that's a good metaphor for people you
need to put your blinders on and focus
straight ahead for 2018 what do you want
out of 2018 more money more happiness
more time more freedom focus that brain
on that thing you can't be this is the
average person's brain in one second
they want to focus on let's say they're
trying to improve their business well
they also think about oh I've got a DM
oh okay snapchat oh my mom's calling me
oh I wonder you know what happened next
Game of Thrones episode focus it can be
as simple as for example make a time
when you check all your social media I
do it I check try to check it once a day
now I'm in the business of social media
so I do check a little more but my
personal side try to wake up focus and I
just go through all my apps one by one
and get it out of the way
15 minutes you know I I have a lot of
social media followers so it sometimes
takes me a little longer I got 13
million or something so I get a lot of
dm's but still I'm not gonna check them
all be real why just because you know so
if you got a thousand or two thousand
followers whatever five thousand I used
to have a hundred followers it took me
ten seconds a day and then I don't need
to check at the average person at work
is checking their email they said like
20 to 50 times an hour
what a waste of life man don't waste
your life if you tell yourself a story
long enough you start to believe it
don't you believe it you act like it I
have Tulsa what a wail out of handcuffed
lightning though Thunder in jail now you
know I'm bad over the last week I
murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between 18 and
250 4 days of taking action for a new
habit to stick I've created a new course
called 250 for confidence or every
single day for 250 four days I will be
sending you a video between 30 seconds
and 5 minutes long that you start your
morning with around
can you feel confident it's absolutely
free check out the link in the
description below to get access